hello everyone i'm james murphy and as
you can see i am on python.org
with some huge news python 4.0 has just
been released
let's take a look pep401 outlined some
of the major changes coming
in python 4 and here are the big ones
we have new old print syntax mandatory
static typing
and stack overflow integration i've
already taken a quick look at these
but i'm just going to go through sort of
the abstract reasoning
and sort of give you my impressions as
we read through it so let's just read
through it together
okay so it's going to tell us about the
new features coming in python 4.
the 4.0 series is reserved for
groundbreaking changes in the python
language
and this is nothing less than that okay
good
ever since the original breaking changes
made in the 2-7-3-0 transition the
community has been primarily split down
version lines
agree surveys have found the average
python programmer spends over fifty
percent of their work time
converting two to three with over ninety
percent of that time
um putting parentheses around print
statement arguments
definitely in python four the old print
syntax
is going to be reintroduced so that you
don't have to change that old code
anymore
it will just start working again that's
awesome
and of course the newer print function
is going to still be supported
next we have a fundamental change to the
type system
uh python was initially developed as a
dynamic type system
but it was too flexible to allow offline
optimizations by optimizing the pilers
in python 4 type annotations will become
mandatory on all function arguments
return types and variables that cannot
be statically deduced
the standard library will be typed
completely with the exception of the
explicit duct type
and so most code depending solely on
standard library functions and types
will not need much change
this is a huge change it's completely
overhauling the type system type
annotations are now
mandatory but what do we get for this an
average speed increase of over thirty
000 percent and memory usage decrease of
50 percent
across the entire standard library again
huge change
huge benefit finally python has long
been known for how easy it is to develop
and yada yada yada we're partnering with
stack overflow to bring
automated stack overflow report yields
uh in short any time an unhandled
exception reaches the interpreter
the source code accessible state of the
stack and heap all variables and values
in scope will automatically
be uploaded and published to stack
overflow along with the relevant stack
trace
as a question to a dedicated python
overflow section
of the site for other users to debug
that means when you have an error you
don't even have to post it on stack
overflow anymore
it's already covered and like i said
before this was just accepted last night
apparently it was a unanimous vote by
the python language committee
and it's coming soon to a python near
you this just all happens so fast i mean
there are so many
new features coming huge changes coming
um i'm not even sure exactly what to say
i mean it all sounds
really really good so i just wanted to
give you my take
uh my first impression on these changes
it's probably going to be like a year
before
you know the release actually happens um
but i'm always looking ahead always
looking forward to that next release
so let me know what you think of these
changes down in the comments don't
forget to like comment and subscribe
i'll see you next april fools yes
obviously this is an april fool's joke
there is no python 4 yet and none of
these things are ever going to be
implemented
in python